ساره بركان وجبل السمروا في محافظه مالا
ينشرقيه جزيره تيجوا الاندونيسيه اليوم
نحو اربع ساعات
نافثا دخانه ورماده البركاني البركاني الى
ارتفاع تفاوت ما بين خمس وخمسه وسبعه
كيلومترات من اعلى فواتي البرهان
للبراكين ومراقبه الكوارث الجيولوجيا من
درجه خطورته الى اعلى مستوى محذرا
المواطنين من خطوره الاقتراب من صفوحي
جبلي سيميرو لمسافه تمتد لسبعه عشر كلم
في المنطقه هنا الذين يعيشون بالقرب من
البركان في اقليم الشرقيه قد بدافع الفعل
الجويه اليابانيه انها تراقب احتماليه
حدوث موجات تسونامي في البلاد بعد
الانفجار البركاني في اندونيسيا وذكرت
الوكاله ان البركان قد يتسبب في حدوثه
موجاتنا تصل مقاطعه اوكيما وجنوب البلاد